all right um thanks for uh
reconvening that we're time for our uh
our second speaker our deep learning
part of the summer school
uh it's my pleasure uh
to welcome uh
just kidding my thing with to blaze
yarakis
uh he leads an organization at google ai
working on both basic research and new
products the team can has
contributed many contributions including
mobile nets federated learning and coral
they've also founded google's artists
and machine intelligence program and
they collaborated extensively with
academic researchers
in a variety of fields um from a
personal point of view i've found blaise
to have
one of the most creative and unique
perspectives on machine learning and ai
and i'm very happy to have him here to
tell us today
uh to share his vision with us today
so uh and he's gonna give his talk live
and we'll um probably take questions at
the end so i hand it off to blaze
thank you so much uh erin for the very
very very kind
introduction and for and for having me
here i
i'm going to share my screen
let's see
okay does that all work
sorry yes does excellent um all right
um so uh apologies for the uh you know
it's it's gonna it's a little bit
a little bit difficult to give a talk uh
remotely without um
you know any sense of the of the
audience and the feedback but
uh you know aaron uh counting on on you
or or anybody else to break in
if if if something is going off the
rails
so i um i wanted to talk about about
three things today
um the first is a little bit of uh
history of computer science
and ai from maybe a little bit of a
different perspective uh than than you
might be used to
and then talk a bit about scale the the
problems of scale the possibilities of
scale
um again from a little bit of a
different perspective than i think uh
you know most most researchers in mlai
are used to
uh and then um and then i want to talk a
bit about what is missing
uh from from the the model of learned
functions uh
and uh and straight state-of-the-art
performance that that most of us
uh think of as as being what we do so um
history of computing uh you know many of
us uh you know the first image that
comes to mind when we think about the
history of computing is
uh babbages difference engine this is a
reconstruction uh commissioned in 2008
by nathan mierfeld
um and uh i believe this one is in in
the computing museum in mountain view
there's another one in
london um and uh amazingly worked
uh when it was built from uh from
babbage's plans
um whether or not it's a computer in the
modern sense is actually something that
bears a little bit
of of thought when um
when babbage was alive he was not best
known as the inventor
of computing but rather as one of the
founders
and fathers of the industrial revolution
uh he was
uh he was all about factories and
efficiency
he invented the penny post uh his
intellectual contributions had more to
do with
uh manufacturing uh than they than they
did with uh with computing
and in his book on the economy of
machinery of machinery and manufacturers
uh there's this one chapter that that
treats the the computing work
um it's on the division of mental labor
we have already mentioned what may
perhaps appear paradoxical to some of
our readers that the division of labor
can be applied with equal success to
mental operations
and then it ensures by its adoption the
same economy of time
a short account of its practical
application and the most extensive
series of calculations ever executed
will offer an interesting illustration
of this fact while at the same time it
will afford
an occasion for showing that the
arrangements which ought to regulate the
interior economy of a
are founded on principles of deeper root
than may have been supposed
so the the thing that he goes on to
describe in this chapter
is the french hydraulic engineer gaspar
the pronis
government-funded project to uh to make
a giant
set of of uh tables of log and trig
functions
uh which was eventually published in in
1791 it was part of the french
government's
uh kind of standardization and
decimalization
uh and rationalization project uh the
sort of post-french revolution
uh proni was in turn inspired by adam
smith's
wealth of nations he uh he basically
wanted to make these gigantic
books of of function tables uh by
building an org chart
and and so he divided up the labor for
doing this into three levels
and uh bragged that he could manufacture
logarithms as easily as one manufactures
pins
which i think is a great uh bon bon so
he talked about the the layers of the
org chart in terms of sections the
zeroth section of course is
prania himself the first section was
five or six of the most eminent
mathematicians in france
uh including legendre and carno and some
others that you may be familiar with
the second section was seven or eight
persons of considerable acquaintance
with mathematics
so you know at the top levels they were
kind of working out the um
the basic algorithms that they would use
which functions would they tabulate over
what ranges and so on and so forth
these would then reduce those operations
to elementary ones
and uh and the bulk of the labor was
this third section which was from 60 to
80 people
using nothing more than simple addition
and subtraction they return to the
finished tables
it's remarkable that nine tenths of this
class had no knowledge of arithmetic
beyond its first two rules meaning
addition and subtraction
since we're usually found more correct
in their calculations than those who
possess the more extensive knowledge of
the subject
in fact uh that third section consisted
almost entirely of
out-of-work hairdressers uh because it
turned out that they had less work to do
uh during this period than they had
while the heads of the nobility were
still on
a few years prior this idea
of of using uh women uh primarily
as the uh as the lower tier of a
computing machine
uh is one that uh that had has a long
history
a longer history than modern computer
science does so
premier was doing it it was also being
done in
in the first uses of punch cards which
was
shown here this is the preparation of
the 1890 u.s census
or the first project in digital
humanities this is this was the index
domasticus which went on for several
decades
um you can see all of the various church
fathers peering over the shoulders of
one of the women doing the
the data entry and computation for this
digital humanities project
or the harvard computers uh which was
the first uh use of large-scale
computation for astronomy
uh also called pickering's harem by the
way that was a pickering on the on the
on the top left and all of the labor
being done by the women
um some of whom ended up being quite
prominent astronomers
in their own right by the way which was
a bit of a kind of hidden figures
story uh even as late as world war ii
uh there were massive compute farms
uh being uh being uh done by by women
uh and uh these were for calculating
ballistics
uh trajectories uh nuclear bomb yields
all sorts of things
now um at the time of of uh um
at the time of the of the early
computers that uh that babbage was uh
uh was was dreaming up uh really it was
his collaborator aydah lovelace
who um who kind of understood what it
would mean for general computation to
happen as opposed to thinking about
these things
as manufacturing processes as as really
just about a kind of
um machine for generating the values of
a function
uh ada understood i think the uh the
bigger possibilities and
uh and they're a remarkable series of of
footnotes in her translation of of
this lecture by minabri on the different
section that really revealed
the extent of her understanding of this
uh she was also
fixing to be an amateur neuroscientist
at the end of her life she had a
tragically
short life cut short by cancer and as
she was
very sick toward the end of her life she
she wrote
the following in one of her letters i
have my hopes and very distinct ones too
of one day getting cerebral phenomena
such that i can put them into
mathematical equations in short a law or
laws
for the mutual actions of the molecules
of brain equivalent to the law of
gravitation for the planetary insiderial
world
the grand difficulty is in the practical
experiments in order to get the exact
phenomena i require i must be a most
skillful practical manipulator in
experimental tests
and that on materials difficult to deal
with the brain blood and nerves of
animals
in time i will do all i dare say and if
not why i don't signify and i shall
amuse myself at least
it appears to me that none of the
physiologists have yet got on the right
track i can't think why
it does not appear to me that cerebral
matter need be more unmanageable to
mathematicians than
sidereal and planetary matter in
movements if they would but inspect it
from the right point of view i hope to
bequeath to the generations
a calculus of the nervous system
um i actually always find this letter a
little bit a little bit um
difficult to read it kind of chokes me
up a bit um who knows what she might
have achieved that she had lived
but as it turns out she wrote this in
1844
99 years later a paper was published
about that calculus that she imagined
a logical calculus of the idea's
imminent and nervous activity
uh warren mcculloch and walter pitts
this was really the last moment at which
neuroscience and computer science were
the same field
and um what mcculloch and pitts imagined
in their models of neurons in the brain
is that they were carrying out logical
propositions logical gating functions
so they imagined the whole brain was
like a a function evaluator
and and that neurons were doing ands and
ors and knots and so on
um and that and that you know that that
all of the mental processes could be
reduced
to uh to a kind of uh a logical calculus
in that way
uh so you know this this uh this drawing
of there is uh you know it's just one of
many in the paper
uh drawings of neural nets and you may
recognize
um that these neural nets and the reason
they're the neurons are drawn as they
are by the way is that they're pyramidal
neurons which
you know have a pointy end and a fat end
and and those loops by the way at the
ends of certain of those neurons
uh represent um inhibitory synapses
which they imagined might be a not
operation
so you know any of you who have seen
circuit diagrams of of logic gates
will recognize that loop on the end as
being the um you know the not loop at
the end of a nand gate or a nor gate or
something i'm pretty sure
that this is that this mcculloch and
pittsburgh is in fact where all that
comes from
in other words logic gates are
artificial neurons
and all of classical computing uh is is
really uh based
on on this um idea of modeling modeling
brains modeling neurons and and
and the gates and there are the
artificial neurons and that
that analogy was very very direct from
mcculloch and pitts to
uh the early designs of the um of the
eniac and other early other early
computers to
touring's seminal papers on on computing
so yeah uh all computers in other words
are neural nets
the difference of course is that a
classical computer uh which runs
ordinary programs and does arithmetic
operations and so on
is a computer in which all of the
neurons are
um you know are are kind of fixed
function and rigid
uh and uh they don't learn rather they
um
uh they're they're wired up into a
certain configuration that does a very
very specific task
uh and executes um operations in series
so uh in that sense um you know these
these early models of brains
really had very little to do with how
real brains work but they had a great
deal to do
with how modern classical computing the
70 years of computing that uh that went
all the way from
uh you know 1940s up until i would say i
don't know 2015 or so
how all of that computing worked now
not all computing was done in that sort
of logic gates
uh sort of school this is frank
rosenblatt in 1959
with uh the very first artificial neural
network
which i'm sure many of you know about
the perceptron uh which could
distinguish between
uh triangles circles and squares uh the
the um the synapses that govern the
behavior of this feed-forward
neural net were actually connected to
potentiometers and motors that would do
uh kind of
uh learning using using something like
reinforcement
so um all of these ideas uh you know
involve
uh involve the the kind of theory that a
brain
is basically a function um and
uh and that if we're going to do
learning uh in other words figure out
what what on earth that function is it's
essentially a regression process
so if you have a really big function uh
like a brain then that means lots and
lots of parameters lots of neurons lots
of synapses
and lots of parameters if you're doing
regression of course also means
lots of data so um so the idea of
size of bigness and of brute force
was sort of built into this idea from
the very beginning um
and uh and and uh you know in the recent
uh experiments with
with gpt3 you know we see that same sort
of of uh
you know what happens if we just make it
bigger more data more computation more
millions of dollars to train and so on
these are uh these are um pods
of tensorflow processing units in the
google data center
the fact that google has access to very
very big data
and very big computing with their you
know giant data centers the biggest
in the world as far as i know um you
know that that's
that's one of the things that made
google a natural place for uh for the
development of a lot of these techniques
uh you know jeff dean when he founded
google brain talked a lot about this
kind of confluence of big data and big
computation
as one of the reasons that google would
really be at the forefront of a lot of
this kind of work and
and he was right it has been
although open ai is certainly giving
google a run for its money
but i believe uh personally that uh most
machine learning in the future will be
done on very small devices
and not in data centers at all and um
and that that might elicit a a-ha you
know especially in the in the uh
in the weeks just after gbt3 um
the reasons are um that i think we can
i think we must and i think it's
inevitable and
i want to i want to run through these
arguments briefly to give you a little
bit of a sense of them
so as far as we can goes uh well
um back in 2017 uh
aaron mentioned mobilenets which was one
of one of one of our our group's
uh earlier outputs and um
mobile nets uh and and many other
techniques uh you know involving
involving uh quantization and model
compression and so on
uh allowed for what what had been really
quite heavy weight
uh in this case convolutional nets
standard kind of machine learning models
to run on uh on small devices uh like
phones uh in real time uh even on the
arm processor uh
now it doesn't even require you know
kind of using the gpu or something
which was quite surprising to me and to
many other people as well that it was
possible to run these large
models on on modern processors uh
because modern processors
uh have so many vector operations
because they are in fact
so fast we've pushed things really to
the limit um and because they're so
um because that that pathway of
miniaturization and speed
uh kind of uh carried moore's law for 70
years and that that really goes places
uh so it's interesting that even on
modern on on modern phones you know we
can actually evaluate you know quite
large neural nets although not of the
sizes of some of these very big ones
we've seen recently
um as for why we must why we must think
about about
about neural nets on small devices well
um you know one of the one of the things
that our team has done
um is uh ship a lot of neural models of
different sorts
on things like android phones um for
uh for a selection of text uh for um
captioning uh for tr you know
translation of of um
of of speech into into text for people
with uh with with hearing disabilities
um and and so on and and in a lot of
these different applications
you really don't want a system in which
the signals are first sent up to a data
center somewhere and then the result
comes back down
um you really want local evaluation
local execution
because of privacy because in many cases
these neural nets are serving as kind of
prosthetics
that are mediating your interaction with
the natural world or with other people
in ways that that you really don't want
another entity to be in the middle of
if that sense you you want you want that
mediation to be entirely confidential
not to be a potential source of
surveillance
and um and whenever whenever you um you
aggregate information
in in the data center you know even even
if you
uh if you have very very strong security
as google does
um you you still are now uh you know
you're no longer in your own home as it
were uh
right you you're now um uh you're now
cycling things through a space that
uh that can be uh surveilled for example
by uh by governments and
and there are real civil liberties
implications to that so uh so making
these things run locally
is important you know we we shipped uh
some features on android like for
example uh now playing a number of years
ago that
do something like shazam that recognize
the music in your environment
uh continuously and in real time that's
much more useful than an app that you
have to launch and you know listen to
the music and get back to
get back the the result you know it
shows up on the lock screen if you turn
it on like what music is playing right
now if you're in the coffee shop
um but there's no way such a thing can
be implemented by having
an audio stream of everything the
microphone here is continuously being
streamed to a server somewhere right
that would be that would be anathema
from a privacy standpoint
but uh when all those things are running
locally it's not a problem it's like a
smart hearing aid essentially
so uh yeah same kinds of things with
face unlock uh
and and certain functionality in google
lens so we've done a lot of work with
these devices to to bring uh uh to bring
various neural capabilities um to a
place where they can run
on on devices um i also think that
that that more and more neural nets
running locally and on devices is sort
of inevitable from us
from a scaling law perspective um
and uh just for a bit more of a trip
down down memory lane in
computing history this was one of the
first
um all um all solid state
uh four function calculators it was a
very lightweight meaning you know it
only weighed about as much as
um i don't know a desktop computer i
suppose
and you can see all these you know 13
boards stuffed with components
uh and you know this this thing in 1969
uh you know eventually eventually turned
into
the google pixel 3 say in 2018 and when
you tear down a you know a
modern phone you don't find boards
stuffed with components inside
what you find inside is actually almost
nothing they're full mostly of battery
and um i don't know if you can see my
mouse when i move it over this
thing but these these two chips are
really the best
uh end of the phone so even the space
inside the phone is not primarily being
used by computations just these little
bits
and um you know the trend toward making
computing
uh work uh as uh systems on chips
uh means that uh nowadays most laptops
you know don't have boards of
of computing in them either i mean this
a system on ship like this one is apple
not only for a smartphone but for quite
a powerful laptop
the entire laptop is basically on this
one board with all of its support
electronics
so um it's a it's a pretty different
world that's why laptops have now gotten
so thin by the way
they're mostly surface and the inside
such as they are consists mostly of
battery
uh you know we get sort of comical
pictures like this one where in uh
memory is so small that needs multiple
layers of adapter in order to just like
result in something macroscopic that can
be plugged into
you know a larger machine which is
itself mostly made out of air
so you know that little 64 gig
thing dwarfed by its adapter you know
now obsolete there are 512 gig
one terabyte and actually even two
terabyte ones
and and just again just for perspective
this was the first
hard drive from ibm the 350 disk storage
unit announced in 1956
stored 3.75 megabytes on 50 magnetic
platters the weight was about one ton
um this is the husky stadium at
university of washington
that's how much area you would have to
cover with those uh with those original
hard drives in order to make 512
gigabytes of storage
uh so a quarter mile on a side never
mind how much power
would be involved and of course uh the
reliability of those things wasn't too
hot either
weight 150 000 tons or 136 billion grams
uh the modern device is about one gram
so
136 billion roughly gives you uh how
much
scaling has gone in from 1956 to present
day
and there's still plenty of room at the
bottom uh to uh to quote
feynman even assuming no further gains
in linear scale 3d structure is barely
there
in modern memory and computation so a
sugar cube
one centimeter or so on a side um
according to feynman's calculations in
his wonderful paper there's plenty of
room at the bottom uh
is um he estimated that that
that about a petabyte would be the you
know the amount of information in all
the 24 million volumes
of interest in the world in 1959 um
and um and in fact um we are
at at a moment in time today where
where uh we can actually store about a
petabyte in a sugar cube volume if we if
we uh stack up
uh uh silicon of the kind that i've that
i've already shown you
so in other words nanotechnology uh you
know it doesn't look like uh lots of
robots swimming around in our blood and
all the other kinds of
fanciful things but nanotechnology has
quietly arrived
and is living in our pockets and purses
even though we're still far from uh from
a lot of that
uh sort of uh you know drexler type
nanotech
when we look at moore's law uh it's the
observation of the number of transistors
in a defense
integrated circuit doubles about every
two years and that um
you know that that has been happening
since the 70s uh this is on a log
vertical axis here's a somewhat more um
detailed view
of moore's law showing the scaling of
various different subparameters of it
and um and you can see that something
starts to go a little bit wonky
in the 2000s we are still in an
exponential
scaling of number of transistors uh on a
die
however around 2006 we encountered the
end
of so-called dendrid scaling and
standard scaling
is as transistors get smaller their
power density stays constant
so that the power use stays in
proportion with area both voltage and
current scale downward with length
and when that stopped happening due to
physics that's when we saw the number of
cores
on a die start to increase above one
that's when we saw the frequency
stop to rise uh you know i i grew up in
a world of computers still being
measured in terms of how many megahertz
or gigahertz
they were running that stopped being
advertised when that number stopped
going up
uh single thread performance of serial
computers therefore also stopped
um but the number of transistors keeps
going up so what are you going to do
with all of these
extra transistors will make more virtual
computers on the same die
lots and lots of processors but of
course if you're using traditional
um computing traditional serial
computing there's a limit
to how much utility you can get out of
multiple cores it's actually
very difficult to program serial you
know computing on
on lots of parallel cores but um
i think it's maybe not a coincidence
that 2006 was also the year
that the deep learning cabal took over
uh the at the time nips now
nurip's conference so um
they in a sense i think they provide the
answer to the end of denard scaling
we know now what to do with all of those
extra transistors on a die
and the answer is neural nets there's a
declining
marginal value of all of those extra
transistors for doing serial
computations
but there's no limit to how many
transistors a neural net
can usefully use uh that's why you know
we have
the those kind of scaling limits in our
own head based on some you know some
fairly
uh shrunky biology but uh you know it
has uh it has a very very large number
of units
uh regardless of whether you measure
that in terms of number of neurons or a
number of
compartments within neurons or channels
even
but they're all running at very low
clock speed uh in parallel
so that's what's going to happen with uh
with the majority of our silicon as well
because we've stopped being able to uh
scale serial
serial computing but we can still scale
parallel computing
and um so many many modern all of the
all of the new
uh chips coming out of silicon
manufacturers
are um are starting to do very large
scale parallel computation to enable
neural nets
to run uh fast and at low power uh
google's
edge tpu which we we released in 2018
can do
uh four tera ops at two watts or 400
frames per second of mobile net v2
uh on this little tiny chip and
everybody's making neural net processors
now
um and in fact uh the um you know this
is a this is the the coral board that
aaron mentioned uh that includes um
edge tpus on it for prototyping you can
use them kind of like raspberry pi or
something
um it can do all sorts of neural
operations uh and do them in
a privacy preserving manner because all
of it is being done uh locally
so things like you know using a camera
to do people counting or to
look at social distancing or use of ppe
or whatever you would like for those
things to
work without uh without surveillance and
it's possible to do that if you have all
those computations happening locally
um but uh but anyway my my point uh with
all of this is just that
uh you know we're seeing um use of
transistors
for neural nets start to dramatically
outpace
the use of transistors for serial
computing and i think that's a
very a very interesting computing trend
as we look to the next decade
so um this fun book from 1691
the secret commonwealth of elves fawns
and fairies
uh was written by robert kirk i don't
know whether he was a true believer or
not
but it's kind of an ethnography of the
spirit world
in um uh in the uk in what is today the
uk and
um uh you know he imagines a whole sort
of uh
society or universe of other intelligent
beings that are not
uh that are not human uh that are kind
of living among us you know in the fairy
circles or
you know under the rocks from the bottom
of the garden what have you
um and uh this um this book by the way
the secret commonwealth
that was the inspiration for philip
pullman's
title uh the secret commonwealth in his
second volume of the book of dust this
is the same philip pullman who
made his dark materials which some of
you may have may have read
wonderful books um but
what phil pullman imagined was that it
was a parallel universe in which
all of us have these kind of witches
familiars we have we have these
kind of animal formed things that are
kind of external intelligences
uh that are also a part of us so you
know the
person's a person's demon or familiar is
a part of themselves
and kind of augments them in various
ways
uh the the uh there's a there was a
movie there was a bbc series which was
quite a bit better than the movie
this word ourself right the the singular
and yet plural kind of comes out of this
idea of demons
and um i think that i think that we're
we're actually kind of um
rapidly moving towards such a world um
you know if
if uh if we're making brains uh out of
silicon that we're uh carrying around in
our in our pockets and purses and so on
there and they and they
perform more and more cognitive
functions then um you know effectively
we
we have entered the world of ferry uh
and there's a lot else
in this world of ferry besides people's
uh personal demons or personal cognitive
extensions that recognize all the music
in coffee shops or the translate between
languages
or recognize objects and what have you
uh so
uh you know i i also think that things
like uh you know a
gene or a spirit that you conjure up in
the car that you know that helps you to
drive
ought rightly to be thought of as
another entity in this kind of world of
fairy
uh it's not a proper entity in this
world of ferry today
which is actually one of the reasons
that it works so poorly so
uh you know a voice navigation uh on on
maps today is kind of called in from a
distance from the data center
and that's why it'll interrupt you when
you're speaking or not
not understand you know sort of what
what lane you're it has no eyes it has
no ears it has no social awareness it's
not sort of
physically present you can't make that
physically present
in the current model that is run from
the data center without uh without
surveillance
so um you know ultimately these things
are going to have to be actually you
know the computation is gonna have to be
present
and separate from the company that made
it and in the car in order to have that
social awareness and do a good job of
navigation and do a good job of
interacting with humans
so so yeah this is the direction things
are going uh and
uh and we have infinite numbers of
transistors with which to do it
and uh and that's why i think the great
majority of neural nets
are going to be um evaluated and learn
and operate
uh in uh in the ferry world which is to
say in devices that live
uh with us among us in environments on
our persons in our persons
in cars in cities and not just in data
centers that kind of call it in from a
distance
doors that open and close because they
recognize people and not and you know
and
don't open the door for cats and dogs
smart dust eventually
you get the idea so where are these
neural processing units headed well um
low clock speed uh and analog
computation are certainly on
on the on the frontiers uh that allows
for very low power
and very low heat dissipation which in
turn allows stacking in 3d
um and and that's what brings us you
know our sugar cube
that can uh that can embed not only you
know a petabyte of data but
uh but possibly on the order of peta
operations per second
uh which is about uh you know perhaps
roughly human brains worth of
computation so you know
we're kind of we're kind of here we know
how to do it
leads us to a prediction uh you could
call this neural silicon law number one
if today there's equal silicon area
being dedicated to the cpu
and the neural computation in devices
every 18 months or so the neural silicon
will double while the cpu stays roughly
constant because there's there's not you
know no further gains to be had from
adding transistors to serial computation
that means that in a decade or so 99 of
the transistors in your personal device
uh will be neural as opposed to
evaluating classical computing
uh neural silicon law number two is that
if those things can be run at very very
low power by down clocking them
then that means that ambient power that
just comes from the difference in heat
between your skin and the environment
or um uh you know or um
ambient radio or light or whatever all
of that becomes becomes part you know
sufficient to power its neural
computation
and uh and you don't need um even
batteries you can run things with
with just a capacitor and uh law number
three
is that the majority of your neurons are
going to be
digital are going to be implemented in
things like transistors as opposed to
in wet wear inside your own head because
the number of neurons inside your own
head is constant
and the number of neurons uh that that
augment you uh via via your personal
devices going
going up exponentially at the moment and
there's no race between the constant
and the next moment so um
so i i hope i hope i've explained why i
think that the idea of big machines
um you know and and big models running
in data centers that cost millions of
dollars to train and so on is not
necessarily the way of the future and i
want to talk a little bit about big data
as well so um
the need for uh for for big data uh you
know is clear if you have
very large numbers of parameters and
you're thinking about things in terms of
regression
um if you want to train something that
is uh doing regression in order to go
from you know
28 by 28 pixel image to a number
then you need lots and lots of copies of
the number uh they all come from
different
human beings that originally wrote all
of those digits
um we um we
invented a technique a few years ago
that uh some of you may have heard of
called federated learning
for um you know not not so much for
disrupting the whole
idea of how learning is done but for at
least
uh changing the terms of the engagement
of people
and the fairy world if you like with uh
with with data
uh and and the way it works is by taking
stochastic gradient descent and
uh and it's and its many variations and
sort of turning it inside out
in such a way that not only does
inference happen on devices out there in
the world
as opposed to in a data center but
learning also happens on devices out
there in the world
so um you know just just doing learning
on a device in the world maybe it
doesn't sound like such a big deal but
but
it might also sound particularly useful
um you know sure
my local device could do uh could
evaluate a gradient and and tune a
weight but if it's only my data that
it's learning from
that's not nearly enough to learn how to
do a complicated task
somehow everybody's information has to
get aggregated together
in order for this to uh to really work
but how do you do that aggregation
without moving all of the data
to a central location well you can
instead think about a distributed model
for uh for the learning algorithm itself
and um uh and the way the way it works
and this these are stills from a comic
that that we that we made about
federated learning because we wanted
policy makers to be able to understand
it as well as computer scientists and uh
and the children researchers
um but um but uh this this comic you
know sort of tells a little story about
about an imaginary uh startup and
it's privacy nightmares and how they uh
how they use federated learning to solve
their their challenge
um but the idea is to not move the the
training data
to the server to keep it on the device
um
to uh to run gradient descent um when
that device
is not busy doing other work so you know
you're asleep it's asleep uh it's
plugged in it's got lots of time and
power
it runs over the examples that it has
observed throughout the day
and um and and calculates gradients and
tunes its weights a little bit
that's by the way the same thing that
you're doing when you're asleep uh
that's why uh you know when we talk
about learning skills or memory
consolidation sleep is so essential to
all of that right
we um there's good evidence that we
don't do a very good job of tuning our
own synapses
uh while we're awake and behaving either
we need that that rest period
to do it so your phone is doing the same
thing
uh but then the real trick comes when
um uh when the uh when the deltas when
those those
gradients and those those uh those
updates are themselves
taken and compressed and encrypted
and um and these secure aggregation uh
protocol is applied which adds
random masks uh to all of those uh
gradients
uh random masks that when they're all
added back up when they're uploaded and
added back up in the data center
cancel out to get uh to get an accurate
gradient from the entire population that
then tunes the network and brings it to
a better state
so this allows learning from entire
populations
without uh without revealing any of the
any of the training data to uh
to the server um
it's it's a um it's a very very
interesting field this one in which you
want to think pretty hard about bounds
on privacy and performance you know if
you if you
uh if you want to de-anonymize a system
like this one you can imagine
taking one step based on one item of
training data and then trying to
reconstruct
the training data from the change in the
weights that's possible
to do but of course if you take many
many steps um
if you uh if you you know average
together lots of training data and take
many steps and tune the network based on
that
then you're no longer able to uh to do
that reconstruction unless your neural
net
is just memorizing rather than
generalizing so a neuron that's doing
the right thing it's generalizing rather
than memorizing
uh will also preserve privacy uh when
when this when this learning happens and
there are various
kinds of differential privacy style
bounds that one can make on that
so it's a hot field uh you know we um we
wrote the first few papers in the
beginning uh google papers dominated
very quickly turned into
a field work where papers made at google
and from our group are a very small
minority
of the papers being published on
federated learning uh there was this
cool paper in december 2019 with lots of
authors advances and open problems and
federated learning that is a fun one to
check out if you're interested in this
topic
i'm also very excited by the idea of
training generative models
with federated learning because um
you know one of the shortcomings of
normal supervised learning with fl
is that you need the feedback signal on
the device in order to know
uh you know how to how to calculate a
loss function but
of course when you're doing unsupervised
learning you don't need a loss function
and generative models are by definition
unsupervised uh
and and therefore the sky's the limit
with respect to federated
learning of generative models so very
interesting possibilities here
and you could of course then train a
generative model to um
that you will then use as a kind of
artificial user or an artificial
ensemble of users to then
uh kind of make an endless private
faucet of data to to do labeled
training data if you want so
i now want to take a bit of a step back
a bit of a turn um
and uh and talk uh for for my last few
minutes
about um about whether in fact it's it's
uh it's reasonable to think about brains
as
just functions um i had a a high school
teacher um uh in in math who
um you know when she was uh teaching the
class um basically the rudiments of
analysis when she was teaching us what
functions were
uh was really at pains to tell us that a
function could be anything you know it
could be something that
that uh took x and delivered uh you know
cosine of x
as the output but it could equally well
be something that took a uh you know
took a picture
of an animal and emitted uh you know
what animal it is
and i thought that was a bit of a um a
bit of a spurious
uh illustration of what a function might
be because i i didn't think that such a
function was physically realizable
um and of course i was proven wrong by
by convolutional nets but you know the
question remains like is it really the
case that
we are just functions you know that we
have some inputs and we have some
outputs and
and and that's that you know we're just
the evaluation of a function
um i mean even in our field we see some
pretty interesting conflicting
narratives between
you know ai which essentially uh makes
the rather grand claim that intelligence
is about functions and regression that
is the same modeling functions based on
data
and data science which is a very modest
term right that really just says no no
this field is not about
real intelligence not about solving ai
it's just it's just about you know
doing a better job of handling data and
modeling and understanding data
we call these things that we make models
we don't call them brains
so there's a modesty behind that but you
know many of us really do want to solve
the uh
the big the big problem right what about
it what about intelligence for real
you know these these narratives are very
different um
so yeah everything we've been talking
about is just regression it's modeling p
of
y given x or p of x if it's a generative
model or an unsupervised model
uh we don't call them brains or people
uh at the same time
in the more kind of popular press we see
this ai narrative
of um you know uh models surpassing
humans
at one after another task othello and
checkers
and in the 80s and 90s uh to uh you know
to starcraft and poker more recently
and that that very much leads to this
you know oh my god you know the robots
are taking over ai is coming
uh sort of story but um
you know what i think it's kind of hard
to avoid when you look at that list of
successes
of models is that they're all about
passing a test or winning a game
uh in other words we are now at a moment
where if you can take a task and break
it down into something that can be
scored
uh that it's a well-defined problem that
has a well-defined metric
uh for merit uh in other words a loss
function that we can define for it
and we can gather enough data then we
can build a neural network that will
achieve superhuman performance of that i
mean i i think we're kind of running out
of problems
that you know that satisfy these
criteria and that we can't you know
build a network that will just kind of
crack it it's actually remarkable to me
how little territory this actually
covers um
it's not how most of life works uh you
know and
you know if you if you're if you're
learning by the way how to drive
right you don't have to crash the car a
hundred thousand times uh in order to
figure out how not to do it
uh the way uh the way uh the way
learning works today but also
you know what what is the loss function
anyway for how you hire people
in your company or what's the loss
function for criminal sentencing
or you know what's the loss function for
for a couple's therapist
you know or for or for evaluating good
art versus bad art
i know um you know schmidt huber tried
to make lost functions for good art
versus bad art but but i i respectfully
uh
think that that's um uh not only the
wrong loss function that he defined but
uh but a but a problem that is actually
not particularly amenable to making a
loss function for
so yeah a great deal of life is not
actually about winning a game
uh or uh or or um or a test or passing a
test or achieving a certain score
um and that's true even a very workaday
sorts of problems that we face all the
time
in in machine learning engineering and
practice like you know how to rank
notifications in android
uh you know what is the figure of merit
what is the loss function a lot of the a
lot of the
the really big problems that we have
created for ourselves as a society
um you know stem with with computer
science the past few years stem from
uh loss functions that are trivial like
maximizing engagement
uh you know with a facebook news feed or
with youtube or whatever when in fact
um you know there is no simple function
that that you can optimize that won't
result in in a
crappy outcome uh and i i want to point
out this is not just an advanced human
issue it's not it's not something that
is unique
you know to um you know to things with
big brains like us
the way uh patricia churchlin put it in
a quote that i really like is
the success of artificial neural nets
not withstanding it must be acknowledged
that their behavior is a far cry from
what a rat or a human can do
as they live out their lives on the
planet all vertebrate species are able
to
detect threats and to behave
appropriately in response to motivations
to survive thrive and reproduce
in this domain as well as maintaining
homeostatic functions there are
typically competing values and competing
opportunities
should i mate or hide from a predator
should i eat or made should i fight or
flee or hide should i back down in this
fight or soldier on
should i find something to drink or
sleep and so forth go ahead and market
something as intelligent but
if it's brittle lacks flexibility and
common sense and there's nothing
approximating motivation or drive or
emotions or moods
it may be difficult to persuade the rest
of us that is intelligent in the way
that biological entities can be
um so i i really i i buy this
i think i think uh uh pat churchill is
correct
um and we can look at some of the very
very simplest life forms
on earth and see this at work uh so
these are um bacteria these are e coli
uh you may recognize
uh some of them are in the process of
mitosis of reproducing
um for those of you who are unfamiliar
with e coli and how they work
uh they've been the subject of a lot of
really uh important
biophysics um uh experiments and theory
uh in um in the past 50 years
and they they have these uh filaments
that come off them uh
these uh these flagella uh with motors
at the base
and and the way the way they work is
that if if the motors rotate one way
then those flagella all bundle together
and form a corkscrew and the thing swims
and it kind of swims forward that's
called a run but
sometimes the motors all reverse and and
when the motors reverse
then the flagella unbundle and uh and
they flail around
uh they don't kind of corkscrew together
like this and and then the
bacterium executes what's called a
tumble meaning
essentially it randomizes its
orientation so uh bacteria are a little
bit like those
those old radio-controlled cars that can
only go forward or
backward and turn um you know and the um
the forward mode is run and the turn
mode is tumble and the turn is random
so if you look at an e coli swimming its
trajectory looks like this
a series of runs alternating with uh
with tumbles or randomizations in
in direction of movement howard berg in
the 70s
uh did a bunch of theoretical work on
chemotaxis and bacteria and basically
showed that with just this one bit
control of running and tumbling
ensembles of bacteria can actually do a
really good job
of following food around and and
the basic trick is that you run more
when the food is declining or low and
you tumble more when the food is high
and if you do that then statistically
you end up with kind of distribution of
bacteria that can follow
the food around this is a little
simulation
to show you how this works so um so here
those uh those green guys are bacteria
and and what i'm what i'm doing is
having them
learn through evolution how to do
chemotaxis so um so what you what you
see is as a
the the red is uh is food and this in
this simulation
uh if they um if they are in the red
they're
eating uh and their energy goes up uh
and if they're not eating their energy
is going down if their energy goes down
to zero they die
um and if their energy goes up beyond a
certain threshold they they get to
reproduce
um and what you see on the on the right
hand side
is uh is a row of uh or sorry uh yes a
row of values
for their uh q table uh for each
bacterium i'm gonna i'm gonna replay it
so you'll see this a little bit more
clearly
so the q tables all start off random and
and they the those q tables just map
the uh the sensory experience of the
bacterium to action to the one bit
action uh runner tumble
um they're not doing real uh
reinforcement learning which you'll be
you know you're you'll be learning much
more about this later in the course
but um but they're just they're just
following a a cue table that maps
observation to behavior and um and
what's happening here of course is the
ones that uh the ones that
that don't have working queue tables
will all end up dying off
and the ones that do have working q
tables will survive and reproduce which
is
evolution and there's one more thing in
this little simulation as well which is
that when two bacteria touch
then they might exchange a little tiny
bit of their of their
of their q tables and that's something
that bacteria do it's their version of
sex
uh that's um so that that that kind of
exchange of little bits of
of of dna is one of the ways that um uh
one of the ways that that evolution
happens in bacteria beyond just the
reproduction of the individual so they
they learn how to do um
how to do chemotaxis as you can see um
yeah those are the rules in in detail
conjugation is the name for the exchange
of the little bits of
of dna and there's some random mutation
throat as well cosmic rays
so um oh and i guess i should have said
also that that
because uh most of them die more random
ones are thrown in when the population
goes below a certain threshold
so so this is um this is learning
through
um through evolution
now the question is is the thing that
has been learned
optimal because you know if you're a
machine learning person then
you're probably imagining that there is
a loss function here
and that and that i have just
implemented an optimization procedure
for learning via evolution there are you
know plenty of evolution
inspired optimization procedures like uh
cma
evolution strategies um and
um uh you know and and this is really
just uh this is really just a you know a
standard kind of regression problem but
being done by other means by by
evolutionary means
but here's the thing um i didn't put in
what the loss function actually was
right so so what is the loss function
system like this
i mean really all we said was you know
if it persists
it exists uh and if it dies it dies
so um there are plenty of papers there's
a rich literature
about you know what um a bacterium might
be optimizing when it's doing chemotaxis
this uh
um uh strong freedman bialic coburn
paper from um
uh uh from the um i don't know if this
is with the 80s or the
or the nine this was 90s this is 97. uh
you know
posits um sort of optimality of of of
food eating right essentially you know a
bacterium should eat the maximum amount
of food possible
that's that's what it's optimizing for
okay so what should its chemotactic
strategy be with respect to running and
tumbling
and you know the the the predictions do
roughly match
with behaviors but um
uh but but the thing is that if you if
you want to try and ask directly
what has been optimized uh this actually
looks like an inverse reinforcement
learning problem
so um so i'm going to kind of turn the
problem on its head a little bit and say
can we can we invert uh the the learning
procedure here
and back out what the uh what the reward
function would have been
that would have resulted in um in in
these bacterial learning what they
apparently have learned
through this evolutionary process so
that is the inverse reinforcement
learning problem
um and uh and and the way we're going to
solve it here because
it's actually quite ill-conditioned is
um
is via a a kind of cheat
a hack and the hack is that
rather than having uh q tables be the
things that uh that the bacteria are
are um are learning in the sense that
that's what they what they have and what
they carry on
it's actually going to be reward systems
that they're learning
so i'm now showing you uh some some
little artificial bacteria that have a
um that have a different uh sort of
universe
they have food and they also have the
ability to emit a chemical
uh which is uh which is rendered here in
blue and they have the ability to sense
that chemical
uh there is no um there's no uh
sort of specification in the system by
the way of of what um
of what that chemical actually um uh you
know should be used to do what it means
right they they kind of figure that out
for themselves
but um but the point is uh sorry i'm
just re-running the simulation here
uh the point is that they uh they figure
out how to use the chemical they figure
out how to eat uh they have a two-bit
output now a mid-chemical don't admit
chemical run or
tumble and um and they're now
individually learning
via reinforcement learning um and
there are a number of different events
that they can that they can observe
happen in their lives
um mating the encounter of another
bacterium eating
the encounter of the chemical um hunger
meaning that their that their their food
supply is running low
and um or um uh or satiation
right uh so so uh imagine that all of
those are events
and that they get a reward positive or
negative for all of those things
they start off with um uh with with
reward systems that are entirely random
that are arbitrarily positive or
negative for all of those events and
the ones that survive and reproduce are
the ones whose reward systems
are actually uh good reward systems for
um for learning what they need to learn
so it's a learning to learn paradigm if
you like
with evolution thrown in and um and they
do learn how to do chemotaxis as you can
see
um and uh and this is the second half of
the simulation which i which i've
replayed now a couple of times
uh is is just sort of figuring out a
little bit about what they have learned
uh with respect to the signal like what
is what is that signal being used to do
um that extra chemical uh what it turns
out they they learn how to do is
is um signal each other collaboratively
so they can follow each other each other
around
um and um and so as a sort of
rudimentary form of sociality is learned
as part of the reward signal for these
bacteria
so um if we do this many many times
then you know the question is all right
what is
um you know what is the optimal what has
been optimized for
what is what are the rewards uh this is
what the answer
uh actually ends up looking like so as
you might expect
um death uh gets a negative reward
uh they don't like death they don't like
hunger they do like eating
they like sex they like food um
so you know all the things that you
would expect um
emit by the way the most negative thing
this is uh this is actually
um the signal this is this is signaling
because signaling is costly i forgot to
mention
uh when they when they signal they also
lose energy faster than they would
otherwise
um so that that that comes off as a as a
negative reward and positive rewards
come from
from from living and from reproducing um
but
um but the error bars i think are in a
way more interesting than just the
uh the the means all of these
are viable um uh bacterial populations
that emerge from this evolutionary
process
uh so some of them love death uh and
um and some of them uh um you know
hate uh food and actually are repelled
by food uh you might wonder like how on
earth can a bacterium that is repelled
by food even even survive
but they they do uh if they uh if they
love signal in some situations so
there are actually all sorts of reward
systems or all sorts of things that can
be getting optimized
that are viable in the work and when you
look at
um at the different populations of
bacteria that have that have learned
different kinds of rewards or different
emotional systems if you want to think
about it that way
they have different collective behaviors
some of them have very small but very
stable populations
some of them have um large populations
do a lot of exploring versus exploiting
um you know so you get kind of like a
wild range of different things and
and and what i what i hope this starts
to uh to to make clear is that it's it's
pretty problematic to think about um
about all this just in terms of of
regression and optimization like we
don't even know
what on earth these things are
optimizing when we try to measure what
they're optimizing we find that there
isn't a single thing that they're
optimizing for
i've done a lot of experiments that i'm
not going to have time to show you that
involve putting these things
into a jar together you know so what
happens if you evolve a bunch of these
things separately and you put them
together and the answer is
you get sometimes competition
uh sometimes cooperation you get
different different uh bacteria that
might occupy different evolutionary
niches if you like
and learn how to work together in
certain ways um
so you know it's it's it's wild and it's
all of the things that you
that you uh expect from nature um
and none of it looks like optimizing a
function
so you know what persists exists
evolution decides
on what is good and bad uh or better and
worse
or better and worse versions of good and
bad it's not exactly optimization
um despite the fact that we do have
evolution-inspired optimization
algorithms
um and and and the the reason that you
can sort of see immediately that it's
not optimization is that
the moment you have two entities
together in an environment like this
even if they were both trying to
optimize for a specific thing
you already have something sort of like
a gan uh right so again a generative
adversarial network is an example
of what happens when you take two
systems that each are trying to optimize
something but
but one of them isn't that they're
interacting with each other one of them
is is looking at the output of the other
one
and vice versa so in such a again
um you don't have something that looks
like uh
like the gradient like gradient descent
whatever you instead have
is a dynamical system in which you have
uh pursuits
and spirals and uh um uh
and chaos sometimes uh and so on and you
know anything that looks like spiraling
anything looks like it has vorticity
tells you right away that it's not
gradient descent because um uh because
whatever
whatever loss function it is that would
be uh would be descended in a gradient
system
that would be the uh the integral of
this thing and you can't integrate
something that that has vorticity in it
right this is not the gradient of any
function
i mean these are steam gans uh don't
even uh
um uh don't even have you know have an
infinite number of of
limit cycles even so you know this is
not this is not something that is that
is optimizing anything
so locally each actor is doing gradient
descent of its own
with some well-defined loss function but
when you put them together the combined
thing is no longer doing gradient
descent
and we can't in general write down the
function that's being optimized anymore
and life is like that at every scale
uh it's it's sort of like the general
relativity of
of of loss functions in the sense that
everything is
perturbing the environment of everything
else and so
you know where we might have thought
about uh just a function getting learned
and optimization of that function the
state of the art result and so on as
being like an isolated particle or
special relativity
you know where the space is fixed
relative to the particle real life
is that every particle is influencing
every other particle and we actually
have
a kind of curved space and the dynamics
of movements in all that curved space
are life
uh not not not optimization there are
many solutions many niches
signaling begets collectivity the
environment is each other
the question even of whether we're
looking at one organism uh one super
organism or lots of independent
uh you know organisms all competing or
cooperating with each other is not
actually very well posed
you know it really kind of depends on
how you look at it
so um so yeah optimization is not how
life works there's no external arbiter
saying what is good or bad it's just you
know like what what persists
gets to stick around and play another
round
and by the way it's also not how brains
work uh and i i don't you know i i'm
definitely not
enough time in this in this lecture to
kind of go into some of our uh meta
learning uh research
on on on brains and on how they work but
but if you think about a brain as being
a collective of neurons that are all
talking and signaling to each other
which is
after all what brains really are um and
losses as being the propagation
of of signals back uh you know it's it's
um
it's it's one it's more like life than
it is like uh like regression
uh i guess is the short way to put it
you know we we only think about the
function as being
the thing that in the end does inference
uh but that sweeps under the rug
all of the learning processes that are
actually used to
train those functions up and when you
start to think about the learning
processes as being part of what
that brain actually does then you
realize that dynamics
and feedback are um are inherent
in um in in what the neural network does
as part of its learning process
and that's in turn contingent or
dependent on the environment outside
of that of that brain um and um
and you're no longer in a world of of of
things that you can think about it's
just uh it's just
functions that optimize something
there's always that that presupposes an
inside and an outside
that don't exist in real life um so okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna um
uh skip my few remaining slides that
have some more mathy bits in them
and maybe open it up to um uh
to discussion um
and uh grand challenges uh so um
the um you know some of the grand
challenges that i think we we uh we face
now
um are you know how it is that um
that that in this kind of multiplayer
universe of lots of ais lots of
intelligences
that learn together i love federated
learning how it is that we can
talk about privacy and agency and so on
in a distributed environment like that
um also if we have um
uh if we have brains that themselves uh
evolve in their not only in their
architectures but also in their learning
rules
uh and in how it is that they learn from
each other how does that all work
uh how can we characterize uh how um
you know how learning occurs in
environments like that um
how can we think about artificial
societies as being things that are
engineered in order to create certain
kinds of outcomes
um large-scale meta-learning in the
federated setting is an especially
interesting crossover i think between
the two things that i have alluded to
and talked about
um how does one engineer artificial
ecologies uh how does one think about
about
bringing dynamical systems theory back
into the picture
when one thinks about learning in order
to understand better
how how learning happens in ensembles
can we define state of the art can we
define soda in a meaningful way
for social environments uh because you
know the asocial environments that we
have right now i think we've kind of
already played them out we've determined
that we can make any damn function we
want but
we're not we're not uh we're not any
closer to making things that are truly
uh intelligent or alive um and maybe
even more fundamentally can we do work
as a research community without relying
on um on these ideas of state of the art
of soda how do we
do the equivalent of hill climbing or
complexification ourselves without
it without it being uh you know a game
with simple rules uh as
it has been uh with things like the
cfart challenges and so on
and uh finally uh if we think about ai
ethics
uh and other related concerns in this
kind of curved space uh
uh environment um you know we that that
poses its own very special set of
challenges i've only alluded
to the problems of machine learning
fairness and ethics but but obviously
those are those are heavily implicated
in everything that i've been talking
about
so i'm getting hoarse and i know i've
tried to cover too much territory i will
stop
there and uh it looks like there are
some questions on the q a uh how
so how should we how should we handle
this uh yeah so we can just go through
the list
um what we did last time was actually
call on people to ask their own
questions even though they've gone ahead
and written it here and we'll get
through as many as we can
and then from there maybe you can answer
a few offline after we're done here
yeah that sounds great by the way well
thank you very much it was it was
excellent i
truly enjoyed your your presentation and
so maybe yeah let's let's just jump
right into the questions
um so yeah so i guess uh bhargav
are you there
yeah do you want to ask your question
oh can you increase your get closer to
your mic
now now it's clear yes
so my question is our brain generates
neurons and uh
okay uh so all right we can read it
upload yeah yeah yeah yeah
then like as we learn in practice but in
deep learning
yeah you're unfortunately kind of
cutting in and out so i'll just go ahead
and read your question
you write uh our brains generate neurons
and connections between them
when we learn and practice in deep
learning we have a fixed architecture of
the model
so can we say that having a fixed
architecture is creating a bottleneck
for human level
or general intelligence in a.i
yes uh yeah i think that it is um so
there
are a couple of different approaches um
you know so so in in of course
um in well i i should also say something
else which is that in real brains there
are of course
a lot of strong constraints on what is
connected to what uh that are coming
from
um uh you know from the the from physics
right from just like what is close to
what
so um you know in in deep learning we um
we can think about uh dense models where
everything is connected to everything
and
and it's all a weight and um and
and you can imagine essentially every
conceivable kind of model
as being just you know a subspace of of
those kind of dense or fully connected
models
and when i say denser fully connected
models by the way i mean more than just
um you know dents from one layer to the
next i mean a real brain
um you know doesn't just have layers it
doesn't just look like
you know a stack of one layer connects
to another it's literally like any
neuron can connect anything else
and um and that's one of the reasons by
the way that back propagation can't
possibly work
in a in a real brain you know you have
to be thinking about you know about
signals for both what we think of as
feed forward and what we think of as the
learning signals
propagating to various other parts of
the brain um but the the way we can
um i believe the way we can think about
architecture search
and learning um as part of the same
framework
is to imagine that um uh that that there
are
um genes if you like that uh that
actually grow
brains and that growing and learning are
are just two different time scales
of the same sort of process uh there's a
beautiful work that alex morvinsev and
collaborators have done with neural
cellular automata
that are worth checking out that that
that um that explore what happens when
you allow
you know structures to emerge from
learned patterns of cellular automata so
if you imagine
you know brains getting grown as soluble
automata
and and the selection criteria on you
know certain brains that survive is one
that can do a good job of learning and
learning together
i think that's the kind of path forward
that feels to be most fruitful
great um so i guess um
do you have uh can you uh
maybe ask your question live
you're top of my list here yeah
i don't know if i can allow you to chat
or not okay
can you hear me okay yes okay thanks um
i think it's more from uh a industry
perspective because
when we talk about scale big machine big
data we
definitely want to leverage some picture
picturing model but oftentimes we see
that it's not adapting to our local
data set or our specific problem that
well
that accuracy is not very satisfying so
i'm just wondering like what would be
your suggestion for that probably not a
fixed
rule for that but i'm just curious what
would be your first
thought or like some solution for this
case if you are in this situation
yeah it's a great it's it's a great
point and one that really
really converges on on the questions
about equity
and ai as it's being done today because
of that very very brute force approach
right so um you know
one of the things that's so interesting
about gpt3 is that it can pre-train with
vast amounts of data
and
allow further data or or fine-tuning
uh that that make it work for a specific
uh scenario
but none of that all of that fails of
course uh if you're if you're working in
a domain
that wasn't well covered by the by the
vast amounts of of pre-training
and um you know that speaks a little bit
to what i was saying earlier about you
know like you don't learn to drive a car
by crashing it you know 100 000 times
there's something very
brute force and extractive about the way
we're training these models today that
just
feels like it's um you know we might we
might be coming out with functions that
are actually quite close to certain
you know functions that do end up in in
human brains but
we're doing it in a way that is
massively inefficient
and as long as we're doing it in those
massively inefficient ways we
um we are going to have a serious equity
problem because only the
uh the parties with the resources to do
that kind of massive brute force
training will be
you know setting up the priors right
like what language is this being done
and or what domains is it being done and
you know who's internet is it being done
and which rapidly it's trying to look
like not not just one internet anymore
right
speaking to the fragmentation in china
and india and so on
um so yeah i they're they're i think
they're profound questions and i don't
have a practical solution for you
given current learning paradigms but i
think it really speaks to the need for
looking at different learning paradigms
that are not so brute force
right for sure thanks let's take um
i don't know this is yon or joan uh
um if you can yeah you should be okay
uh yeah it's yone it's a weird finnish
name um
yeah so mike my question let me just
find it here um
right so i'm wondering about the sort of
current state of these uh
this edge device uh machine learning you
kind of answered my first question which
was going to be about uh
whether they can be trained on edge
devices that can happen via federated
learning
but i'm wondering if there's any sort of
advances in the forward passes we do
uh on on the edge devices like can we do
some bayesian stuff like can we
incorporate uncertainty
in our outputs or or stuff like this
because i mean
uh bns with with stochastic weights
those those can be
uh pretty tough to work with and you
know if you
doing mc high dimensional mcmc on a on
an edge device seems like a daunting
task so i'm wondering
where we stand where we're at with that
yeah it's a good question and it's it's
really at the interface of
of the physics of how we do uh you know
sort of neural computational edge
devices
and um and algorithms and and and the
the you know the state of our theory
about these things so um you know we we
uh we certainly are looking at
non-traditional you know kind of analog
computing
uh you know and stochastic kinds of of
operators right that can potentially be
you know work at much lower
uh uh uh much lower energy um
uh or um or use a lot fewer transistors
i mean
the idea that the idea for example that
you're using um uh
arithmetic logic units essentially add
and multiply or max multiply accumulate
unit
units in order to evaluate neural nets
is kind of crazy
right because those things are designed
for accounting they're designed for you
know the number being
being precisely correct at the end of
the story and we know the number being
not precise you know the number doesn't
have to be precisely correct uh you know
that's why quantization works
so uh you can use a lot fewer
transistors
uh if you um uh if you allow you know
for that lack of precision
and do things more in the analog domain
and use other components there maybe not
even transistors
but memristors and so on um and then
and then that that requires that you
rethink uh of course your training
algorithms and your and
and your um and your inference protocols
as well and you'll be able to simulate
those effectively so you can really
experiment with them and develop new
theory
so um all of that is super interesting
um you know uh
uh i i don't know if that quite
addresses spot on your
your question i mean there you talked
about about you know mcmc
kinds of techniques that that um at
least the way they're done today
are are really hard to do on uh you know
on a single edge device or to or gang
together lots of edge devices to do that
that is true
um but you know the the design space is
i guess
what i'm saying is the design space is
yes a lot bigger than we than we
normally think about it as and and
thinking in a more embodied way about
what is actually possible to do these
devices
opens a lot of doors thank you
great um
there we go hi uh yes can you hear me
yeah
so uh you mentioned that we will have
npus in the future and they'll be able
to do analog computing so i was
wondering what is analog computing
yeah yeah that's what i was just
referring to i really just mean that
instead
of representing uh say values of
activation at an artificial neuron
as a floating point number or a fixed
point number
it can be for example the charge of a
capacitor um
and uh you know and so you know if you
if you do that
you can shrink the number of components
a lot uh it also means that you're
that that things lose precision a little
bit and lose the ability to you know to
characterize fully uh the way you can
with fully digital logic
but um but if it means an order of
magnitude more neural computing that's
you know at an order of magnets with
less power that's a pretty good
trade-off
i see where would quantum computing fit
in all this
i don't think it does um i i differ
from hartmut nevin uh my my uh my very
snazzily dressed
and clever colleague uh who runs the
quantum computing effort in this regard
um you know hartmut is uh uh you know
well i think i think i've finally won
the argument of like brains don't really
use quantum computing
if i can start with against
which is not to say obviously the
quantum effects are not relevant to how
brains work i mean without quantum
effects there would be no atoms and so
on so obviously
we use them in that sense but um but we
know that we know that um
uh you know that insofar as our brains
are mysterious
they're not mysterious because of
quantum spookiness i think that's
pretty well established um
i i you know the hardwood claims that
that it may be possible
um uh maybe not to speed up inference
but perhaps to speed up learning
via quantum tunneling so think about
about about the optimization problem
uh in in ways that quantum tunneling
benefits learning in some way
the the trouble with that um it's a long
discussion but the very brief version is
that quantum tunneling only works if if
you have a kind of pin cushion like
energy landscape with lots of
very skinny energy wells and thin
barriers between them
and uh that's not the way uh training
landscapes work
for uh for neural computing in general
they they're they're
bigger and they have uh you know
mountains that you have to tunnel
through rather than thin walls you have
to tunnel through
so it's not clear to me that that the
quantum computing is going to be useful
uh any time soon for either either the
inference or learning passes in neural
computation
but obviously who knows i mean there may
be some discovery that turns all of this
on its head
thank you all right and then we'll give
the honor to the last question we'll
squeeze one more in uh maddie can you
select
one of your questions
uh yep so this is gonna be pretty hard
um
so i this is super interesting work it's
actually like really cool
where again i'll find out more about uh
the experiments on like essentially the
learning the reward function and as a
kind of like a combined question
um what are your current intuitions or
thoughts on
how the local like optimization affects
the global optimization because that is
a
like a key problem in learning
it is um yeah okay you've cheated you've
asked all of your questions
um so um first of all with respect to
like where do i find out more
um yeah we're actually quite behind in
in
in publishing some of this stuff and and
to be honest part of why we're quite
behind in publishing it is because it's
it's
you know we don't have state of the art
results for a lot of the
for a lot of the of the sort of more
wacky techniques that i was talking
about later in the talk
um you know partly because they weren't
really designed to generate
state-of-the-art techniques
insofar as they are state-of-the-art uh
the the way they are state of the art is
generally learning from very very small
numbers of examples
very very rapid convergence um you know
and that's and that's true of a lot of
learning to learn
type schemes that you know they really
shine uh in
in the small n uh domain of of samples
but um but you know some of this is
really just sort of like you know some
fairly profound
like trying to work our way through you
know these these
uh you know so very fundamental
questions like what does it even mean to
make progress
you know right how do we how do we know
that we're doing something worthwhile
uh you know as we as we start to
experiment with some of this stuff which
is obviously relevant
in the sense that it it obviously breaks
some of the assumptions that are
obviously wrong
in what came before but but in the
process of breaking through those
barriers we've also kind of like broken
our compass you know we've broken our
our our
our ability to know when we're actually
making progress or not
so we're we're trying to feel our way
through that right now um you know there
are
there are um um there are some public so
you know any anything anything um you
know alex morgan
savvy you know he's more aggressive
about putting some of his stuff out
there
uh not via traditional publication
methods there's distill
dot uh pub you know kind of things that
are pretty cool
uh michael evan has done a bunch of work
in biology that i think is extremely
relevant to this
um and there's some collaborations that
we have with along those lines
um and uh and as for the um
as for the federated learning federal
analytics and and the the challenges of
all of that
um we we've been running these uh small
workshops on federated learning
uh in recent years um that are worth
getting hooked up to
a quirkshop and i think i believe there
will be one at nurips again this year
um that will go into a lot of those
questions in in in great in great detail
uh so that's a very active community um
and one that is one that's worth
connecting to to
understand some of the some of the
things that you're raising
cool all right well thank you very much
uh we're gonna have to leave it there
um but blaze thanks again for the
excellent really
insightful talk and i'd like i'd ask all
of
our our participants to to think about
the things you've heard here today
because
my own experience uh the kinds of stuff
that he's talking about is just becoming
more and more true as the as the
research community progresses to ever
more complicated problems
and it's uh it was amazing how many
things that just during your talk that i
was thinking about that these methods
that
are you know state-of-the-art methods
where the objective function doesn't at
all describe the way in which it works
and so there's plenty of fascinating to
connect those thoughts so
anyway thanks again uh it was truly a
pleasure thank you
thank you thank you so much it's really
really uh really my honor
and uh yeah i i hope this generation
uh you know figures out some of the
things that have eluded the previous
ones because
figuring out what what comes after
optimization feels to me like the
fundamental problem of
of post-capitalism and post-human
population growth and many other things
as well i think these are really
profound waters
yeah so so yeah it's on your shoulders
guys
thank you so much blaze i just wanted to
add that he will be back
because i know there were a lot of
unanswered questions but we do have a
breakout
um with blaze at 4 15 so we'll
try to carry over those questions left
unanswered into the breakout later on
today
thank you again and a quick break we'll
meet back with marco baroni in 15
minutes